KENDRA PUGH: Hi.
Today, I'd like to talk
to you about search.
Previously, we've talked about
ways to model uncertainty and
also how to make estimations
about a particular system when
we're observing it from the
outside or when we don't have
perfect information.
At this point, we've almost
got enough components to
attempt to make an autonomous
system.
But at this point, we also
haven't enabled our autonomous
systems to make complex
decisions for itself.
This is why we want to be
able to encode search.
Or we want to be able to enable
a system to make an
evaluation of a succession of
decisions, or a succession of
actions, when there are multiple
choices and possibly
multiple choices
at every level.
So as a consequence of being
able to do search, our
autonomous system should be able
to complete a successive
grouping of actions.
In 6.01, we're going to be
searching state spaces.
And searching state spaces
borrows a lot of ideas from
state transition diagrams, or
what we already know about
state machines.
When we're searching a state
space, we want to know what
states we're searching, what the
transitions between them
are going to look like, or how
the access to the transitions
from a given state to all the
states that are its neighbors.
We're going to want the start
state to be specified so we
know where to begin.
We want a goal test, which
actually specifies what we're
looking for as a consequence
of the search.
Or if we get to a state and we
want to know whether or not
we're done, we use
our goal test.
And it could look at the
output of the state, or
actually just the state name,
that sort of thing.
The other thing that we're
going to have while we're
searching is a legal
action list.
The searches that we're going
to do today, you and I are
going to be able to see the
entire state transition
diagram at once.
But if we're encoding how to
search on our robot, our robot
can't see the entire state
transition diagram at once
because if it could, then it
wouldn't have to do search.
It would know how to get
there from here.
Therefore, we give our system
a legal action list, or all
the actions that it
should attempt to
do at a given state.
It's entirely possible that
there aren't legal transitions
at every state for every
legal action.
But it's good to have an
exhaustive list of things to
try and see if they succeed or
fail and, as a consequence,
what state you end up visiting
every time you try
to do one of these.
Being able to do search
is great.
But we also want to be able
to keep track of where we
searched and how so that once
we're done searching, we can
actually execute
the best thing.
We're going to use a search tree
to keep track of where
we've been and how
we got there.
Search tree is going to
be comprised of nodes.
It's otherwise going
to look like a
directed, acyclic graph.
And it's going to have a lot
of similarity to any
particular state transition
diagram
that we end up searching.
But it's going to have nodes
instead of states.
Nodes are different.
Nodes represent both the state
that you've visited as a
consequence of expanding its
parent node, the parent node,
or the place that you came
from as a consequence of
getting to that node, and the
transition that you made in
order to get there, or the
action that happened that got
you from the parent
node to the child.
Keeping track of a list of nodes
is known as a path, or
it specifies where you've been
and how you got there.
And if you're at a given node,
you can actually use the
reference to the parent node and
the action to trace back
from whatever node you're at
currently to its parent node,
to its parent node, to its
parent node, and then finally
get back to the start state.
At that point, you'll know
what path to take.
So the only thing left to do
is, how do you figure out
which paths to follow first?
That's where the agenda
comes in.
The agenda is going to be the
collection of all partial
paths you've ever created as a
consequence of expanding nodes
and then putting its child nodes
on a partial path meant
for future expansion.
The order in which you add and
remove things to the agenda is
going to determine what your
search tree looks like.
That's a lot of information.
At this point, I'm going
to go over an example.
We're going to search the state
transition diagram.
We're going to start at A. And
our goal test would be whether
or not our state
was equal to E.
Today, we're going to
try two different
kinds of basic search.
One is referred to as
breadth-first search, or BFS.
And one is referred to as
depth-first search, or DFS.
Breadth-first search refers to
the idea that as you build
your search tree, you're going
to exhaustively expand all the
nodes at a given level before
advancing to the next level,
or all the given nodes at a
given depth before expanding
to the next depth.
This means you're being
very thorough.
It also means that you're
guaranteed to find the
shortest path from your start
node to the goal if it exists.
Depth-first search
is the opposite.
As a consequence of depth-first
search, you're
going to expand all the nodes in
a given branch as far down
the tree as you possibly
can before
advancing to the next branch.
It takes up a lot less space
than the breadth-first search,
but it's not guaranteed to
find the optimal path.
Another way to think about these
two types of search is
that if you're doing
breadth-first search, then
your agenda acts as a cue.
First items in, or first
partial paths that you
discover, are the first items
out or the first partial paths
that you end up expanding.
Depth-first search is when the
agenda is used as a stack, or
the first partial paths that
you visit are the first
partial paths--
or, the most recent partial
paths that you visited are
going to be the partial paths
that you first extend.
First in, last out.
Or, last in, first out.
Let me walk through a couple
iterations on this state
transition diagram.
And hopefully, it'll be clearer
what's going on.
The first thing that happens
is that you end up visiting
and expanding the start node.
That's pretty straightforward.
So the path A is going to be
added to both agendas.
And the node A is going
to be visited first
on both search trees.
If, in the general sense, I say
that I'm going to make a
transition to states in
alphabetical order, and that's
the order in which I'm going
to add them to my agenda,
that's going to be reflected
in what I write up here.
Let's say that I'm going
to visit new nodes in
alphabetical order.
So nodes I would visit are B and
C, and I'm going to add AB
and AC to my agenda.
Here's where the difference
between breadth-first search
and depth-first search
comes in.
In breadth-first search, because
I'm following the
convention first in, first out,
if I place the partial
path AB in my agenda first, then
I'm going to expand B as
a consequence of the partial
path AB first.
So when I go to B, I'm actually
going to expand B now.
I'm going to look at the nodes
that I can visit as a
consequence of expanding B. The
ones that I can visit are
C and D. And I'm going to add
the partial paths ABC and ABD
to my agenda.
So AC, I'm just going to move to
the front of the queue, or
the agenda, and I'm going
to add ABC and ABD.
And I got there through B. So
I'm going to add C and D here.
Depth-first search
grabs from the
opposite end of the agenda.
So the first thing I'm going
to look at is AC.
I'm going to expand to C, look
at the nodes that I can reach
as a consequence of expanding
C, and visit B and D.
AB is still hanging out here.
I popped off AC to use it in
order to expand C's children.
And I'm going to add ACB
first and ACD second.
Note that our search trees
already look different.
And we'll actually end up
reaching the goal using one of
these search strategies first
than the other, or as opposed
to the other.
If I go back to breadth-first
search, I'm going to pop the
partial path AC off the
front of my agenda.
I'm going to expand C. Expanding
C gets me B and D.
I'm going to move over my
existing partial paths.
And add ACB and ACD.
I've staggered these in order
to indicate that they're a
consequence of a third
iteration of
breadth-first search.
But they're actually considered
to be at the same
depth, since their parents are
considered to be at the same
parents of the start node.
That's the defining feature of
breadth-first research is the
fact that we're going to
exhaustively search a given
depth in our search tree before
advancing to the next
depth level.
If I run one more iteration of
depth-first search, again, I'm
popping partial paths off
this end of the agenda.
I'm going to expand D.
D one transition
available to a node.
And in plain old fashioned
breadth-first search and
depth-first search, I run my
goal test when I visit a node.
So at this point, I would
test whether or not
E was my goal test.
I would discover it's
my goal test.
My search would return
successfully and return the
path found.
So AB and ACB remain
on the agenda.
I popped off ACD in order
to expand D. And
I found this path.
At this point, I've concluded
depth-first search.
I'm going to do one more around
of breadth-first search
to demonstrate an
important rule.
If I pop ABC off the agenda and
move all these over, if
I'm looking at ABC, and I look
at the children of C, the two
children of C are B and D. So
the first partial path that I
would end up adding to the
agenda as a consequence of
expanding C in this case
would be ABCD.
And it would look like this.
You'll notice that we're going
to create an infinite loop.
And there are two basic rules of
basic search that I need to
emphasize now to prevent you
from doing things like
creating an infinite loop.
If you look in the textbook,
they're called "How to Not be
Completely Stupid."
If at any point you're visiting
a node in your
partial path that already exists
in your partial path,
don't add it to that
partial path.
You'll prevent yourself
from creating a cycle.
Because if you visit the same
node more than once, you've
actually done more work
than you need to.
The second rule--
and it's not demonstrated
well on this
state transition diagram.
But, for instance, if I had
two arrows from B to D,
there's no particular
reason to consider
both of these actions.
And if you have a state
transition diagram that allows
multiple transitions from one
state to another based on
different actions, then you need
to come up with some sort
of rule to decide between
the two actions.
That's the second rule of how to
not be completely stupid is
-- if you have more than one
transition from one state to
another as a consequence of
doing search, pick one and
come up with a rule
to pick one.
This covers basic search.
Next week, I'm going to talk
about dynamic programming,
costs, and heuristics.